[Music]
isolations look so cool but they can be
such a huge challenge to learn but with
these five drills I'll get you started
on the right foot Drex here from Drex
Factor po sharing with you the love of
Po spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I'm going
to take you through the five best drills
that I know to help you get down your
poy isolations before we dive in though
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca fests flow toys
juggling calling pyrro ter light toys
spinballs and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-b buus
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission poy
isolations are eye-catching and a
phenomenal personal challenge they're
also really difficult to get down the
kinesthetic awareness that it takes to
learn isolations can take a long time to
develop but that doesn't mean that there
aren't some methods that we can use in
order to get some shortcuts so today I
want to share with you five of my
favorite drills that help you build up
that kinesthetic awareness and get you
into your isolations faster and more
cleanly and whether you've just started
off or you've been spinning for years I
guarantee I will have at least one drill
on this list that will help you out with
your isolation technique so let's dive
in drill number one driving
Styles all right so you'd be forgiven
for thinking this is a bit of a non Seer
but stick with me for a second because
this is one of my favorite drills to
give beginners in general it starts off
by just performing a pendulum that is
you want to have the PO just kind of
hanging beneath your hand as you move it
around in a big circle this means that
you want to take energy away from it as
you're going around over top and let it
fall down to the floor as it is going
down beneath your shoulders from here we
want to switch over into doing
extensions that is now we're putting
enough energy on the PO that it's going
to spin above our hand as we are going
from side to side finally we're going to
go ahead and add a petal at the very top
making the poy go around our hand as it
continues on its way in that big circle
so we want to move between these three
different possibilities we want to go
pendulum extension ins spin flow
pendulum extension ins spin flour the
reason being this teaches us something
very important as we're switching
between these three different
possibilities we have to add and
subtract energy to the poy that is
knowledge that's going to be super
helpful to us in creating isolations
because similarly there are going to be
points where we have to add energy to
the poy and take it away in order to get
that nice feeling where both the poy and
the hand are moving around a circle of
the same size it also doesn't hurt that
this drill just helps in general for
maintaining control over the momentum of
the POI whether you're playing around
with isolations or flowers or any number
of other transition tricks such as
pendulums or stalls this is actually
going to help you get full control of
the Poise momentum which is really going
to come in handy all right so next up
we're actually going to play around with
something that looks like an
isolation drill number two linear is
oltion all right so at the very least
this one has isolation in the title even
if it's not necessarily what we would
recognize as a conventional po isolation
but it is still important here's why now
when we're performing linear isolations
what we're really looking to do is we're
moving our hand from side to side and we
want to go ahead and do that in such a
way that the poy gets to spin around the
hand as it's doing that so if I start my
right hand POI spinning clockwise over
on my left hand side I will drop my POI
down my Center line and as my hand
passes above the PO head I bring it all
the way out to my right hand side so
essentially we drop down as the right
hand is going over to the right hand
side coming back we want to pop the PO
head up our Center Line and sneak our
right hand underneath it so it is
dropping over to the right and popping
over to the left Drop Pop Drop Pop we
want to learn how to do the same thing
with the left hand same direction though
same thing we bring it over to the left
hand side spinning clockwise we drop it
down our Center Line take it over to the
right pop it up our Center Line take it
over to the left we drop we pop we drop
we pop it's also helpful to learn how to
do this with the hand moving up and down
a vertical line so for example I can
start my right hand down here near my
waist and I will pop the poy head out to
the right as my hand reaches up to the
top and pop my PO head out to the left
as it drops back down pop out to the
right
pop out to the left pop out to the right
pop out to the left same thing with the
left hand pop out to the right pop out
to the left pop out to the right pop out
to the left now when we put these pieces
together we can actually create a nice
little combination of these linear
isolations that allows us to bring our
hands very close together and create
little moments that look very much like
an isolation is taking place the pattern
for this is with my right hand out to
the right side and my left hand on the
left side my hands come together my left
hand will go up my right hand will go
down my hands come together my right
hand goes up my left hand goes down my
hands come together and then back out to
sides and we repeat so again after the
sides they come together left up come
together right up come together and out
to the sides so we go together left up
together right up and back out to the
sides here here here
here over and over again and hey look at
that that spot in the middle there sure
looks a lot like an isolation now
doesn't it while not technically an
isolation in and of itself performing
this exercise will give you a feel for
what happens when your hands lock into
that position where they're separated by
a single Poise length this is really
important not just for identifying what
the feel of an isolation is eventually
going to be but also this gives you a
transition tool in and out of isolations
to be able to switch back into other
flower based tricks as well all right so
giv you two drills now that are
isolation like but still give you some
basic understanding of what the trick
looks like now let's actually dive into
the trick
itself drill number three stirring the
pot so this is actually the first drill
that I ever encountered for learning how
to do poy isolations and I want to say I
got it from a Nick Wy video way back in
the day but the thinking essentially
boils down as such when we're performing
isolations in wheel or wall plane we are
having to fight gravity and that is part
of of what makes this such a challenging
Endeavor but we can kind of learn
isolations with training wheels by
simply performing the same motion but in
a horizontal plane this is called
stirring the pot all right so here's how
this is going to work you're going to
start off by marking the center of the
PO either you can do this in your
imagination or you can do it physically
with say a Sharpie or a piece of tape
and once you got that midpoint marked
you're going to let the PO hang beneath
your hand as you look down I want you to
try and spin your hand and the PO head
both around that midline it does help
here if you have it actually marked
because then you can just visualize it
being kind of Frozen in space as you
spin both the POI and your hand but
essentially you just drill keeping the
POI head and hand at opposite ends of a
circle by visualizing the midpoint of
the POI as being the middle of that
Circle as well this is also a useful
exercise just for getting down
horizontal isolations and in general
which I personally think are an
underutilized horizontal plane trick
they look really cool and bonus they
give you skills that'll be helpful for
performing this trick in a vertical
plane all right you've learned how to
add and subtract energy from the poy you
have learned how to create things that
look like isolations and now you've
performed isolations in a horizontal
plane now it's time to actually bring
those isolations into a vertical plane
drill number four the
crank all right so straight up this is
the most powerful drill I have ever
encountered for getting down isolations
here's the way it works you want to go
ahead and take one hand and stick it out
in front of yourself like you're about
to block a karate chop your other hand
is going to hold a poy you're probably
going to want to shorten it up just a
little bit and you're going to hang the
poy behind the forearm of the arm that's
reaching out in front of you here's why
what you're going to go ahead and do is
you're going to try and move your hand
around your forearm like so but you're
going to try and keep it continuous such
that your PO head and your hand are both
going around your wrist at the same time
and this just in and of itself is way
more challenging than it first appears
if you go too fast through it then you
wind up with the PO flying off into
space if you go too slow the poy just
wraps around your arm and you never get
started the whole point of this is
finding that balance point where both
the poy head and your hand are both
moving at the same time it should be
said that some people kind of have a
little bit of a cheat that the do with
this exercise when they're first
performing it namely as they have their
hand and POI going around their forearm
they'll start moving the forearm as well
to try and help out the PO as it goes
around this is fine when you're first
starting off and quite frankly if that's
where you find yourself within your
first few repetitions of trying it it's
not a bad place to be in but once that
is working for you dare yourself to try
and keep your forearm as still as
possible and just let your hand and po
go around that wrist that'll be when you
know that you've got the technique down
all right let's say that you've got the
basic mechanics of your isolations down
and you're starting to experience some
success performing them now what drill
number five the four
positions all right so no BS this was
the drill that finally made the Pieces
come together for me and made it so that
I could perform isolations whenever and
wherever I wanted to here's how this
works you need to start off by
essentially imagining that there are
four quadrants around your body you've
got your backside you've got your front
side on the front side you're going to
be spinning in your dominant Direction
mine is clockwise and on your back side
you're going to be spinning in your
non-dominant direction that's
counterclockwise for me now on each side
of you whether it be the front side or
the back side you also want to think
that there's a bit where you're going to
have your left hand in front and a bit
where you're going to have your right
hand in front this is where it is
helpful to have down those skills of
knowing the lanes of poi this is a thing
that I teach in order to help you keep
your POI spinning split times same
direction in wall plane I will go ahead
and leave a link to a video on how to do
that down in the description as well as
up in the cards if you're watching on
YouTube but essentially you want to be
able to do your planes such that you can
do your left hand forward and your right
hand forward both on your clockwise side
as well as your counterclockwise side
all right so our next step here is that
we want to try doing reps with our hands
and POI in all four positions so we want
to try and do 10 reps with our left left
hand forward spinning clockwise 10 reps
with our right hand forward spinning
clockwise 10 reps with our right hand
forward spinning
counterclockwise and 10 reps with our
left hand forward spinning
counterclockwise once we have all four
of these positions down we can actually
just walk around in a circle with them
we can imagine transitioning back and
forth from each side of our body as we
keep our isolations going just by
switching back and forth which hand is
in front the thing I love most about
this drill is that not only will get you
more comfortable with performing your
isolations in general but it grants you
full Mobility with your isolations too
so you can work them completely into
your flow and be able to gain full
Mobility with them this a trick that a
lot of people are even struggling to try
and do at all now if you're looking for
a little bit more Hands-On help with
your POI isolations you're in luck cuz I
am teaching a live stream po dance class
all about isolations and how to move
with them not just the kind of basic
skills that you need in order to get
isolations down but how to get true
freedom of movement with them and be
able to dance around with them I can
bring people on screen to help them out
with individual problems and every
single class is recorded so you can go
back and watch it whenever you'd like to
learn more about that course you can go
to crowdcast doio drexfactor poo and as
a special offer to people who have
watched this video you can get 10% off
the price of the course when you use the
code isolation at checkout go check that
out and please join us what are your
favorite tips for getting down poy
isolations let me me know down in the
comments also be sure to like share and
subscribe to help other people find this
video and to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without all of my amazing patreon
supporters in particular I would love to
give a shout out to my flow patreon who
are listed on screen right now uh if
you'd like to check out some more
tutorials that I have on intermediate
and beginner poy Trix I'll go ahead and
leave a link to a playlist of those down
in the description uh also if you would
like to support the channel I have a
patreon I will leave a link to that down
there as well pretty pretty please I
need your help to keep these videos
coming uh thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
peace